Tiny motion sensors known as accelerometers
are at the heart of much of today's
technology. Built into a smartphone, for
example, the sensor detects both movement and
the angle at which the phone is being held
to trigger the rotation of the screen.
This little chip is why a smartphone knows
when it has moved.
These motion sensors are tiny but smart
because they can detect every move.
They start with silicon discs called Wafers.
Each wafer will be used to make thousands of
motion sensors.
A technician aligns the discs in a cassette
using the flat part of each one as a
reference point. Once properly aligned, a
mechanism lowers the silicon wafers onto a
carrier made of quartz because it can
withstand intense heat.
The technician loads the wafers into the
furnace inside 100 degrees Celsius heat and
steam cores, an oxide to form on the surface
of each wafer.
It'll act as an electrical insulator.
Then it's into what's known as a sputter
system.
Here, inert gas ions bombard aluminum,
causing it to sputter onto the wafer until an
even layer accumulates.
This aluminum layer will serve as a
conductor of electricity.
The next machine deposits a light sensitive
chemical onto the wafer.
The wafer spins, allowing the chemical to
flow evenly across the surface.
This all happens under the glow of yellow
light to prevent the untimely activation of
the chemical which reacts to bright light
just like an unexposed photographic negative
would. They're now ready for that bright
light.
Uv light beams through tiny patterns on a
glass plate to activate the light sensitive
chemical. The patterns transfer to the
wafers surface, forming an outline for
thousands of motion sensors.
Another chemical then flows onto the silicon
wafer to further develop these minuscule
images. Next, lasers locate the wafers, flat
edge,
signaling a chuck to spin it into proper
position for plasma etching.
The etching creates thousands of free moving
3D structures.
Each one is a motion sensor.
After etching, a sprayer blasts the surface
with carbon dioxide.
It's the only way to clean it without
damaging the now movable sensors at the next
station. A robotic arm flips the wafer into
position, a tray moves under the robot and it
places the wafer on it.
The tray retracts and loads the wafer into a
clamping system.
It then collects a second silicon wafer and
places it on the first one in the clamp.
The second wafer acts as a lid to protect
the individual sensors held in the clamp.
A machine heat seals the two wafers and the
bond is complete.
Next, a computerized saw cuts grooves into
the top wafer only while a steady stream of
water keeps the dust down.
The saw exposes the aluminum layer on the
bottom wafer, something that will allow each
sensor to make an electrical connection.
The platform now moves the wafer a
millimeter at a time so that a probe can test
each sensor and confirm it performs
correctly.
This continues until every sensor on the
wafer has been tested from a plain silicon
wafer to a unit that contains thousands of
motion sensors.
This process has taken three weeks.
After the individual sensors have been cut
out and encased in plastic, they're ready for
a final test.
A robot loads each sensor into a test
socket.
The socket both tests the sensors
performance and programs it to customer
specifications. A robot packages the sensors
for shipping and once installed in phones,
tablets and computers, these motion sensors
will be ready for action.
If you've been to an airport, you've seen
mobile belt loaders on the tarmac.
They drive from the terminal to the
aircraft, align their built in conveyor belt
with the entrance to the cargo hold.
Then load baggage or cargo on board when an
aircraft arrives, they do all that in reverse
to unload baggage or cargo.
A turn of the control handle adjusts the
height of the front of the belt loader,
enabling it to reach the cargo hold of even
the tallest aircraft.
The rear height is also adjustable, so the
airport baggage handlers can set it at a
level comfortable for loading the vehicle.
And the conveyor belt are separate units in
this part of the factory.
Workers construct the conveyors steel frame.
They weld together all the steel parts.
Then grind all the weld seams flat so that
the belt will move over the frame smoothly.
Workers install across member just past the
midpoint of the frame.
It will connect with two sets of lift arms
installed in the vehicle, one which raises
and lowers the front of the conveyor.
The other which raises and lowers the rear.
Workers insert alignment pins to position
the cross member on the frame correctly, then
weld it in place.
The vehicle's chassis is also made of welded
steel.
Workers blast the chassis and conveyor frame
with a metal abrasive.
This removes rust and other debris, prepping
the surface for paint to adhere properly.
They caulk all the welded seems to prevent
corrosion, then spray a coat of primer
followed by a coat of industrial grade paint
in the color the customer requested.
Once the paint dries, assembly can resume on
the conveyor frame.
They install the motor, which drives the
belt.
There are two options available This
hydraulic motor powered by the vehicle's
engine or an electric motor powered by
battery.
The motor rotates two large metal rollers,
one at the front of the frame, the other at
the rear. The belt wraps around these
rollers so that when they turn the belt,
moves between the end rollers running the
entire length of the conveyor.
Workers install 58 smaller metal rollers.
These form the floor of the conveyor and can
support up to a tonne of cargo.
The motor runs these rollers forward or in
reverse, depending on whether the belt is
loading or unloading the aircraft.
The belt itself is made of high strength
tyre grade rubber with an anti-skid texture
on the surface to be long enough to loop
around the seven and one half metre long
conveyor plus the end rollers.
The belt is 15 metres in length.
The ends have teeth which fit into each other
like a zipper and fasten with a metal pin.
Elsewhere in the factory, technicians
install components on the vehicle chassis.
First, the front and rear axles.
Then on each axle, two wheels with tyres
specifically designed for long life on the
airport tarmac.
At the rear of the chassis.
They install the hydraulic cylinder which
raises and lowers the rear lift arms.
Then the vehicle's engine, which can be
either gas, diesel, propane or electric
powered. The vehicle drives at a maximum
speed of just 43 kilometres per hour, but
that's more than sufficient for traveling
between the terminal and the aircraft.
After installing the power steering system,
technicians run wiring for the lights and
other electrical components, run hydraulic
hoses for the brakes and lift cylinders and
install the controls for the conveyor.
They install the hydraulic cylinder, which
raises the front lift arms, then connect the
fluid hoses to the hydraulic pump.
Next, they install the front and rear lift
arms, along with the safety brace underneath
to use when mechanics are working beneath
the conveyor.
They attach the lift arms to the front and
rear cylinders, which expand to raise the
arms and retract to lower them.
Now workers hoist the conveyor over the
vehicle and bolt the front and rear lift arms
to the cross member on the conveyors
underside.
The two units are now one mobile belt loader
ready to roll off the line and hit the
tarmac.